So I searched for AVAudioUnitTimePitch example, and
I came across a stack overflow page that was promising.
By the way, a link to this website is also available in the instructor notes.
This page pointed me to some code, and
also highlighted a video on a website called.
WWDC.
Now, WWDC, or
World Wide Developer Conference in an annual event Apple hosts in California,
where Apple engineers showcase new technologies to software developers.
One video in this website was particularly helpful.
It's called AVAudioEngine in Practice.
I looked through this video and
discovered a new way of working with sound in iOS 8.
A link to this video is also available in the instructor notes, and
I recommend that you bookmark it now, and watch it later.
By the way, you will need the Safari browser to play this video.
This video and
the previous [INAUDIBLE] page led me to some code, and here is that code.
Now, before I run this, I want you to read through this, and
see if you can translate this code into simple English.
By the way, this is the sort of activity that expert software engineers will do
on a daily basis.
See if you can make reasonable guesses about what's going on here, and
then you can submit your answer in this box.
You can refer to the lines in this code by the line numbers that
are provided here.